у при 1000 кремль за свою свою долю
у конфлікті на донбасі
Росії 7 систем відображається ж 40
мільйонів доларів на Петромка сама
прога краще на і днр і c тільки на
виплату пенсій на верхову через нових
витрати ці цифри на правах анонімності
та підтвердив агентству bloomberg
покривні стресу протистів
сховатися серед самої Росії жадібним
чином не пізно chaiti на виплатах
росія по праву seiko на меч ній
проблемах середовище не країни на іскітіма на
нафту і озна святого мур інку а також
санкції буду і чи треба ви витрачають ці
лікарі
абсурдної ситуації поляків тому що таке
шпонку у вигляді 30 руки цьому закликав етапі
рибу новий розпаду ріднянської спілки
в цілому руси його 3 5 мільярдів доларів
нарік на петрін куни викликаних республік
педро хува ала американсько приватно
розвідували та аналітична компанія
stratfor
за даними і росію широкого трояна
стрибнути на абхазію 300 мільйонів
доларів і по 100 мільйонів на 5 днів
цим і придністров'ям якимось катю руку
росія ви робили мої ж два з половиною
мільярда доларів на Петромку кримом і
ціни в ракову че оборонних ви дотки в
створ жуть у stratfor та україна завжди
буду головним пріоритетом для Росії та
цін зміниться а лоза as easy as the java
шаром харчуванням про контекст Рут з клану
ріканське вино зі скільки
домагаються надовго і годину закріпіть себе
вуса разом на морському районі
табун відсіює рача устілкою ресурсі та
розміщу їх ризики та бази у сирії русину
махаєте позиційного ти себе і до низів
ногу партнера вашингтона для ви вирішення
зброю нову конфлікту в сирі їм
домагається до промені ти башара асада до
переговорів американські аналітики
stratfor apricot на щось більше
організації таких переговорів з
одержання штати заклади там здивує росії
тим більше можна вистоїти від нього крізь
з бриджами в пливун акули чародійські
республіки теж б'єш її в сирі і кислому
підв'язуванні студії ми на сході України